do you like killing your characters no I  don't then why do you do it so much  George I do think it needs to be done  you know Valar morghulis all men must  die I think it's part of life and and  art needs to reflect life certainly  since the days of Tolkien so many  fantasy novels have uh been about war if  any writer is going to write about war  then I want him to treat War honestly I  think everybody who died in any Warth  thought they were a hero right to the  moment that the bullet blew off the top  of this ago so it irritates me when I  I'm watching a movie and or reading a  book and the hero is going through  incredible dangers him and his six  buddies and none of them die in a word  if you're going to write about fearful  situations I want you to have fear and  the right kind of fear